reading interviews with you guys it
seems that even between
spectre and this film sort of the role
of bond women has kind of evolved and
developed is that fair yes yes because
then i came back
i love it and developed
because in terms of the script a lot to
be made of phoebe wallabridge uh coming
on board so did she change things
yeah she changed things and she she
wrote like uh for us for lashana as well
and she's great but um
i mean uh
she she's great i wish i'm i'm
you know i feel like you hate her
you know i love her like i'm a huge fan
actually but i just i saw her like
briefly on set oh okay and i wish i had
more time oh we didn't we didn't have
enough time with her yes we'd had you
know she's very very very busy so yeah
we gotta sort of like for snippets but
she came in and she sort of had
um a big influence on the script and i
think allowed um
you know she's one of the
best around um and
made a
she freed up a lot of things allowed us
all to kind of be a bit i mean i think
for lashana she was really important
including yeah she was she was brilliant
as soon as i knew she was on board i
kind of secretly officially said oh i'm
i'm in fleabag like unofficially
this is great
i'm auditioning for flubay um
and we had a very direct conversation
about who she should be and i said my
thoughts and she was like yeah just that
i'm gonna write that that's exactly what
it is because what amazes me is that you
know you think this is a multi-million
pound
film and yet it sounds like it's quite
collaborative like you had late night
sessions working with phoebe didn't you
uh
at the end of one day yeah actually we
um
there's one moment where uh just
i know it's it's daniel's last film and
trying to elevate it as much as we
possibly could so
you know trying to do the best the one
thing i hate when we're you know as a
young actor is going home and lying in
bed and thinking man it could have been
that much better so i try to remove that
in any at all costs now so i had enough
gumption to go to daniel i'm like the
scene i think could use a little bit
more work and
i remember your face and your look
you're like you take care of this
i'm done
but uh no we we started to talk about it
and uh our great producer barbara
brockley and and michael wilson you know
they actually gave us a day off they
said you know what let's actually work
on it and instead of trying to fix it on
the day while the cameras are rolling
you know let's go into an office we sat
down with kerry fukunaga our director
and this really complicated scene we
were we were
you know trying to fix we finally had a
moment after three hours and we broke it
and we got it and it felt so damn good
and to that point i stood up daniel
stood up and you know he gave me a big
hug and
and then he planted a kiss on my cheek
oh on his cheek how tender and it's very
tight
it was actually very tender a little too
tender
yeah i look around the room and i said
well hey man does that make me a bond
girl
[Applause]
[Music]
you